¿Sabíais que en Europa hay un
país que a lo largo de los años
ha cambiado tanto que hasta se ha movido de lugar?
Sí, me habéis escuchado bien. Y no estoy
exagerando. Estoy hablando de Polonia,
el país que se desplazó al Oeste,
y no de forma figurada. Fijaos.
(Polonia tiene como país una de las historias más
difíciles del siglo XX. Invadido y sometido una
y otra vez, este país estuvo bajo el control de
los alemanes, luego fue invadido por los rusos,
más tarde ocupado otra vez por los nazis, poco
después de nuevo los soviéticos hicieron lo
propio y por último terminó siendo un país
satélite de la Unión Soviética hasta 1989.
Sin embargo, ahora su suerte parece
muy distinta. Desde su adhesión a
la Unión Europea en 2004, Polonia
ha sido uno de los países europeos
con mejor desempeño económico. Su PIB se
ha disparado un 164% entre 2004 y 2021.
Un crecimiento un 20% superior al cosechado por
la República Checa durante en ese mismo período,
muy similar al de Letonia y tan solo un poco por
detrás del conseguido por Estonia o Lituania,
dos de los países más exitosos
de Europa en la última década.
Para que os hagáis una idea durante este mismo
periodo de tiempos economías como la española
o la italiana apenas crecieron
un 34 y un 16% respectivamente.)
De esta forma, aunque todavía le queda
mucho camino hasta alcanzar a la Europa
más desarrollada, Polonia se ha convertido,
gracias a su mano de obra relativamente barata y
bien cualificada, en toda una potencia industrial.
Además, sus 38 millones de
habitantes le otorgan un peso
demográfico considerable en el viejo continente.
Por ejemplo, Polonia es el quinto país
con más peso en el parlamento europeo,
con 52 de los 705 europarlamentarios,
lo que le garantiza -en teoría- una
fuerte voz en el seno de la Unión Europea.
Y además, ahora, como ya os hemos
contado aquí en VisualPolitik,
el país está construyendo una de las fuerzas
armadas más grandes de todo el continente.
Así que teniendo en cuenta todo esto,
cualquiera podría pensar que Polonia
tiene todos los ingredientes para
convertirse en uno de los países más
fuertes e influyentes de la Unión Europea.
Sin embargo, stop, no vayamos tan deprisa.
La realidad no suele ser tan sencilla, y si
algo caracteriza hoy por hoy a Polonia es,
precisamente, estar fuera
del mainstream de Bruselas.
Y, queridos amigos, amigas, en esta
ocasión la pregunta es muy clara,
¿Hasta qué punto puede Polonia convertirse en toda
una potencia europea en términos geopolíticos?
Pues bien, veámoslo.
T1 (EL CHICO MALO DE LA CLASE)
Amigos, amigas, la cuestión
polaca es complicada…. Sí,
durante las últimas décadas la historia
polaca ha sido, fundamentalmente,una
historia de éxito. Sin embargo, no todo
es de color de rosas… Ni mucho menos.
Particularmente con el actual gobierno
del PiS, el Partido Ley y Justicia,
que ha protagonizado un
choque directo con Bruselas.
Algunas decisiones como el intento de
incrementar el control del ejecutivo
sobre el sistema judicial o la
respuesta dada, por ejemplo,
a la cuestión LGTB hizo que desde el año 2015 el
país fuera condenado prácticamente al ostracismo
en la Europa Occidental, incluyendo
las altas esferas del club comunitario.
Ahora bien, ¿qué sucedió en 2015 para
que uno de los casos de éxito europea
se convirtiera a ojos de Bruselas
en una especie de oveja negra? Pues,
digamos que fue el año en el
que el PiS llegó al poder.
(El PiS, el partido Ley y Justicia, es
un partido perteneciente a la derecha
conservadora, con tintes nacionalistas,
populistas e incluso algo euroescéptico.
Así que desde el primer minuto
su objetivo fue muy claro:
bajo su gobierno Polonia ante pondría los
principios tradicionales y morales del país
a cualquier campaña o narrativa procedente de
Bruselas. Unas campañas que según denuncian,
están dominadas por una ideología
demasiado sesgada a la izquierda.
Lo que supuso también poner en cuestión los lazos
con Alemania, una amistad que el anterior gobierno
de Donald Tusk, Primer Ministro de Polonia
durante 7 años, se preocupó mucho por impulsar)
Y ojo, hemos dicho poner en cuestión la amistad
con Alemania, pero lo cierto es que también
podríamos decir perfectamente congelar,
romper incluso volar por los aires. Y,
además, lo podríamos decir sin
el más mínimo titubeo,. Fijaos.
(“No hay duda, viendo las acciones de
la UE, que va a ser un continente bajo
hegemonía alemana… Esta es la implementación
del Cuarto Reich.” - Marcin Romanowski, [ Pron:
Martsin Romanovski] Subsecretario de Estado
en el Ministerio de Justicia de Polonia)
(“Nosotros no encajamos en los planes
germano-rusos para dirigir Europa. Una
Polonia independiente económica y
socialmente, y fuerte militarmente,
es un obstáculo para ellos. Desde una
perspectiva histórica, esto no es nada
nuevo.” - Jarosław Kaczyński, [PRON ES:
Yarósuav Kachinski] líder del partido PiS)
Duros, ¿no os parece?
Pues bien, luego otro momento que contribuyó a
enfriar las relaciones de Varsovia con Berlín,
París y Bruselas fue la tajante negativa polaca
de acoger refugiados durante la crisis migratoria
del 2015. Su justificación fue que en gran medida
no se trataba de refugiados sino de inmigrantes.
Una posición, que le supuso a Polonia
ganarse la imagen de país insolidario,
racista y xenófobo. Así que, como os podéis
imaginar, en aquel momento este país se
convirtió casi en radiactivo en los círculos de
poder europeos. Nadie quería acercarse a ellos.
De hecho muchos analistas políticos
llegaron a calificarlo como país paria.
¿Y qué supuso en la práctica todo esto?
Pues por ejemplo que la Unión Europea bloqueara
la entrega a Polonia de los 36.000 millones
de euros de los fondos Next Generation de
recuperación post-COVID que le corresponden.
Y de hecho así ha sido hasta que hace poco, y
gracias al papel que está jugado Polonia en la
guerra de Ucrania, se ha relajado la tensión.
Aunque eso sí, no sin muchas controversias.
(Mayo de 2022 - La UE está ‘ultimando’
un acuerdo con Polonia para el plan de
recuperación COVID de 36.000 millones de euros
Bruselas se está acercando a un acuerdo
con Polonia para liberar decenas de miles
de millones de euros en subvenciones y
préstamos tras un año de estancamiento,
dijo un alto funcionario de la UE.)
(Julio 2022 - Bruselas cuestiona las
reformas judiciales de Polonia para
desbloquear los fondos de recuperación de la UE
El primer pago de Polonia de los fondos
de recuperación de la UE corre el riesgo
de retrasarse después de que la Comisión
Europea detectara que faltaba un elemento
clave en las reformas judiciales
propuestas por el país. - Euronews)
Ahora bien, esperad un momento,
porque esta no es toda la historia.
Durante los últimos años, y mientras era
una y otra vez amenazada y sancionada por
la Unión Europea, Polonia ha desarrollado
un rol regional muy fuerte y ha liderado
alianzas como el Grupo de Visegrado
o la Iniciativa de los Tres Mares,
de la cual también os hemos
hablado ya aquí, en VisualPolitik.
Y ahora, tras la invasión rusa de Ucrania,
ha quedado patente que el rol de Polonia es mucho
más importante de lo que nadie hubiera pensado.
Atentos.
T2 (EL NUEVO PARADIGMA POST-UCRANIA)
La historia que comparten Polonia y Ucrania no
siempre ha sido tan buena como la
amistad que los une hoy en día.
¿Queréis un dato? Según las encuestas, los
ucranianos eran el segundo pueblo que menos
simpatía les producía a los polacos
tan sólo por detrás de los rumanos.
(La relación histórica entre polacos y
ucranianos ha tenido muchos episodios
negros. En 1943 y 1944, por ejemplo,
se calcula que diversos asesinatos
en masa a manos de partisanos nacionalistas
ucranianos relacionados con Stepan Bandera,
acabaron con la vida de entre 70.000
y 100.000 polacos en Volhynia.
La idea era limpiar étnicamente
la región de Galicia del Este,
que hoy en día forma parte de Ucrania, para que
nunca jamás volviera a ser polaca. Por su parte,
la resistencia polaca respondió con el asesinato
de entre 20.000 y 25.000 aldeanos ucranianos.
E históricamente lo que más ha molestado a
Polonia ha sido que alguno de los perpetradores
de estas matanzas hayan sido venerados
como héroes nacionales en Ucrania.)e
Ya sabéis que el siglo fue terriblemente
duro. El caso es que tan recientemente como
en 2018 el parlamento polaco aprobó
una Ley que declaraba como “ofensa
criminal” negar los crímenes
de nacionalistas ucranianos.
Ahora bien,, esperad un
momento porque a pesar de esto,
las cosas de un tiempo a esta
parte han cambiado radicalmente.
De hecho, Polonia y Ucrania son el vivo
ejemplo de que en muchas ocasiones dar
por zanjadas las rencillas históricas
es la mejor decisión posible. Hablamos
de dos países que se convirtieron
mucho antes de la invasión rusa de
Ucrania en estrechisimos aliados. Y,
ahora por supuesto, lo son aún más.
Amigos, amigas, Polonia lleva
años guiando a las autoridades
ucranianas sobre qué reformas hacer y cómo
mejorar su economía, sus instituciones y su
sistema político para adaptarse a un
eventual acceso a la Unión Europea.
Sí, digamos que Polonia se ha convertido
en el modelo a seguir para Ucrania.
Todo esto por no decir que los inmigrantes
ucranianos se han convertido en la mayor comunidad
extranjera de Polonia, un país que, recordad,
no es receptor sino emisor de emigración.
Pero la pregunta que seguro muchos os
habéis hecho es…. ¿Y por qué demonios
ahora se llevan tan bien dos países que
durante décadas prácticamente se han odiado?
Pues lo cierto es que esta sólida alianza
es algo que no solo le interesa a Ucrania,
sino que también está en
el centro de los intereses
estratégicos de Polonia. Y
lo es por varios motivos.
Por un lado, para Varsovia, salvando
Kaliningrado,Ucrania es una especie de buffer,
de zona de seguridad respecto a Rusia. Algo que
ahora para Varsovia ha quedado totalmente claro:
(“Vivamos donde vivamos en Europa,
debemos ser conscientes de que los
ucranianos están defendiendo no
solo su independencia y soberanía,
sino también Europa entera. Putin nunca se
detendrá, él expandirá constantemente su
imperio.” - Mateusz Morawiecki, [Mateush
Moravietski] Primer Ministro de Polonia)
Asimismo, por otro lado, Ucrania le
permite a Polonia incrementar y mucho
su esfera de poder e influencia en toda
Europa. Y no digamos ya si en un futuro
Ucrania termina formando parte de la Unión Europa.
Pensad que juntos, estos dos países
tendrían más de 80 millones de habitantes,
lo que supondría igualar la población de
Alemania y, por tanto, su representación
en las instituciones comunitarias.
Además, si tenemos en cuenta a otros
países políticamente cercanos a Polonia,
como los Bálticos o Eslovaquia, Varsovia
se convertiría en una de las capitales
más influyentes del viejo continente.
[Ya sabéis, hay que pensar con perspectiva]
Ahora tras la invasión rusa de Ucrania este rol y
está ambición de Polonia ha
quedado más clara que nunca…
Por ejemplo, Polonia no sólo es el país que
más gasta en defensa de todo el este de Europa,
sino que además su esfuerzo se va a
multiplicar durante los próximos años
para convertirse en uno de los ejércitos
más fuertes de todo el viejo continente.
(Polonia duplicará su gasto militar
mientras la guerra en Ucrania se recrudece
Polonia más que duplicará su gasto militar
el año que viene, hasta 138.000 millones de
złoty (29.000 millones de dólares). Además, el
gobierno planea gastar hasta 40.000 millones
de złoty (8.560 millones de dólares) para
comprar armas en el extranjero. - Bloomberg)
Esto es algo de lo que os hablamos
con todo detalle en un reciente vídeo
que os dejo en la descripción:
Pero, la cosa no va sólo de gasto militar.
Lo cierto es que durante el conflicto de Ucrania
Polonia ha cogido delantera y se ha convertido
en uno de los grandes protagonistas políticos,
en el mayor receptor de refugiados y uno de los
mayores emisores de ayuda. Por ejemplo, hasta
la fecha, más de cinco millones de ucranianos
han pasado por Polonia y más de dos permanecen
allí viviendo desde que diera comienzo la guerra.
Además, desde que los rusos lanzaron su
campaña de aniquilación y destrucción,
hemos visto a los líderes polacos viajar
constantemente a Kiev y lanzar un montón
de comunicados y declaraciones en
inglés dirigidas fundamentalmente
a la Europa Occidental… Que se ha movido
de forma muuuucho más lenta y timorata.
(El propio gobierno polaco lanzó en abril del 2022
una campaña internacional para sacar los colores a
los líderes occidentales de países como Alemania.
Hablamos de la campaña #StopRussiaNow, “detengamos
a Rusia ahora”, que el propio Primer Ministro
polaco presentó en su cuenta de Twitter.
Una campaña con la que Polonia estuvo
paseando vallas publicitarias móviles
por diversas capitales europeas con eslóganes
e imágenes especialmente duras y críticas.
Incluso hay un canal de YouTube del
gobierno polaco dedicado específicamente
a denunciar a los líderes europeos por su
tibieza a la hora de ayudar a Ucrania.)
Varsovia no ha dudado en liderar la respuesta
europea a Rusia, en liderar el bloque de países
del centro y el este de europa que apoyan
a Kiev y en presionar al resto de socios
comunitarios. En cierta forma esto ha
puesto sobre la mesa el enorme capital
político que Varsovia lleva años
construyendo más allá de Bruselas.
Incluso no ha dudado en echarle un gélido
jarro de agua fría a la fuerte relación que
unía al gobierno polaco del PiS con el húngaro
y ahora para muchos líder prorruso Viktor Orbán
(“Confirmo las palabras del Primer Ministro
Orbán de que los caminos de Polonia y Hungría
han divergido.” - Mateusz Morawiecki, Primer
Ministro de Polonia, el 29 de julio de 2022)
Pero más allá de Hungría lo cierto es que
Varsovia se ha convertido en la capital de
referencia del este de Europa, incluso
en lo que respecta al eje atlántico.
Una posición que le ha hecho chocar
frontalmente contra los viejos jefes
del club europeo. Fijaos por ejemplo en
las palabras que pronunció a comienzos de
septiembre del 2020 el presidente francés,
Emmanuel Macron. Unas palabras que estaban
dirigidas como un puñal directamente contra el
gobierno polaco y también contra los bálticos:
(“Debemos hacer todo lo posible para
conseguir una paz negociada. […] No
dejar que Europa se divida será un desafío diario
para todos nosotros. Tampoco debemos alinearnos
con los tipos más belicistas, que correrían el
riesgo de extender el conflicto y cerrar las
comunicaciones por completo. Tampoco deberíamos
considerar dejar que algunos Estados europeos
en nuestro flanco oriental actúen solos".
- Emmanuel Macron, Presidente de Francia)
Hay un abismo cada mayor entre las posiciones
de Europa occidental y las de la Europa Orienta.
(De esta forma por un lado tenemos
al eje Francia-Alemania, y todos sus
grandes aliados periféricos como España o
Italia, que están deseosos de poner fin a
la guerra y negociar con Putin, aunque sólo
sea para asegurarse el suministro energético.
Por otro lado, tenemos al bloque
oriental, liderado por Varsovia,
que defiende armar hasta los dientes a Ucrania,
vencer a Rusia, romper completamente con Moscú
y reforzar los lazos con Washington y Londres.)
Y ojo que hablamos de una fractura, de una
grieta cada vez más grande que amenaza,
incluso, con partir la Unión Europea en dos.
Y Varsovia quiere estar preparada para liderar uno
de esos dos bloques. Lo quiere hacer
desde el punto de vista política,
desde el punto de vista económico como
la gran potencia industrial de la región
y también desde el punto de vista militar. Y en
este juego, Ucrania puede jugar un papel clave.
Queridos amigos, amigas, quizás
no seamos conscientes de ello,
pero en Europa está emergiendo una nueva
centralidad paralela a la fijada por Bruselas,
París y Berlín. Un nuevo bloque europeo
mucho más proamericano, probritánico, pro
Otan y con posiciones políticas muy alejadas
del mainstream que reina en la actual Unión.
Y eso, eso es una enorme oportunidad para que
Polonia pueda convertirse en una de las grandes
potencias políticas del viejo continente.
Así que como veis está guerra ha puesto
sobre la mesa muchas más cosas que la falta
de humanidad y sensatez de Vladimir Putin.
La guerra de Ucrania ha puesto en jaque
incluso el liderazgo de París y Berlín y
puede terminar cambiando para siempre la Unión
Europea. Lo que parece claro es que a la guerra
de Ucrania le sucederá una nueva guerra, esta vez
de carácter diplomático, en el corazón de Europa.
La pregunta es, ¿terminará Polonia
convirtiéndose en una especie de
contrapeso político al tándem París-Berlín
dentro de la Unión Europea? ¿Hasta qué punto
puede influir el bloque del este en
la política comunitaria? ¿Creéis que
hay riesgo de que la Unión Europea tal y
como la conocemos pueda partirse en dos?
Déjanos tus impresiones en los comentarios
y abramos debate. Y por supuesto si este
vídeo os ha resultado interesante no olvides
darle a Like y suscribiros a VisualPolitik.
Muchas gracias por estar ahí,
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.